can you speak to the issue of cova
denial and delusion amongst family
members and friends
that is somehow if you are a family or a
friend you are not you are not an
asymptomatic and will not wear masks in
each other's presence
hopefully that didn't get cut off
there's the rest of a question that i
don't see anywhere here
so um how do you like
how do you talk to people who um imagine
i mean i don't even know what the
narrative sounds like in your head but
um
i know
i i'm seeing a very dumb breakdown in
conversation
yeah which is the
i think it's the right has a point which
is
that how we respond to
this pandemic should be
sensitive to all of the costs including
deaths that will arise
because of lockdown for example
and that we are not doing a holistic
analysis we're missing how many deaths
will be caused by
economic failure blah blah blah all
those things right
this then results in a rejection of the
idea that we should be doing drastic
things because the death rate isn't what
we feared it might be
right i don't think the death rate is
where it's at at all
right so you know i saw somebody we
respect on twitter the other day say
you know the rate of death for
kids under 16 is below
some very low number tell me again why
schools
um are still happening remotely and the
answer is well
you know if kids can get it and they can
and they're going to bring it home
and they will and somebody else is going
to catch it and they will
and it's going to damage their heart or
their brain
then what is the cost of that
interaction so
that at least though is really complex
right so that the costs of schools being
virtual to both the kids and their
social development
and the parents and their inability to
have their lives
is huge and
the fact that kids themselves don't
appear to be getting sick is
true even though all of these other
things are true um
i i'm not sure where i fall out on
what i think should be happening and
very and i think it's different in
different parts of the country different
different parts of the world um but i
can tell you for sure that virtual
schooling is a farce
oh it is it's a farce right um and
um so you know what what are we doing
this question though is both difficult
but i think a little easier which is
um it's not necessarily easier in the
moment
but how do you talk to people you know
people in your circle
when like oh i finally get to see you
but actually given that we don't live
together and aren't breathing the same
air all the time we either have to stay
far apart or mask and be careful because
why is it that you imagine that you're
like
why have you decided that um you're
inherently safe for me that's not your
decision to make
right right so i have been having these
conversations and typically i will take
somebody outdoors
to have a conversation and i'll say not
to beat them up behind the woodshed
those are different people we don't have
a wood shed that's part of the problem
oh right
um but i will take people outside and
i'll say
hey let's have this conversation outside
where kovit does not apparently transmit
yet at least the other thing that i will
say
when people are like you know isn't this
uh mass business silly i'll say you know
i think people have it wrong
you should see the a you should go to
the subreddit of
people who have tested covet positive
and look at the people who have
long-term symptoms that don't seem to go
away
you should also look at the data on
heart damage
and long-term brain damage and you
should realize that we don't even know
whether you get long-term immunity after
you've had this whether the thing might
reside in neurons blah blah blah blah
and so the point is you say all here are
all of these unknowns
now the question is what do we do it's
not clear to anybody because until those
unknowns are answered we don't know what
the costs are
but yeah you know it may be that
everybody
you know you make let's say that half
the people who got covid are going to
lose
a decade or more off their life that's
probably extreme but yep
but we don't know one way or the other
it could be a larger number and smaller
number of years
right seems more likely but but the
point is and we you know
if you're going to get it every five
years uh because it's going to circulate
and your immunity doesn't last
what does that say to us you know so
they're all of these things and
from my perspective i don't know how we
get to the conversation
which is let's talk about what we should
have done
right we should have really locked down
for a much shorter period of time
right we should not be dealing with
schools coming back in virtual form
we should have taken six months later
six weeks and we should have done this
properly
and we should have put everything
necessary
to get highly reliable testing so the
con the combination
of a very intense brief lockdown
followed by
um very accessible high quality testing
would have been enough
and the point is somehow we're or this
or even absent
super high quality testing uh pooled
testing
uh that allows you then you know at the
at the end of it like okay
what does i think university of arizona
maybe is is
is testing their student population this
way and actually keeping numbers low
compared to like every other college
campus that actually so by pool testing
you pull a bunch of people together and
if anybody tests positive then you do
the fine grain so it's like
like everyone being regularly tested a
lot you know frequently but you know
every test is like 100
inputs from 100 people and you have to
have very very low
false false positives for this to work
yes um
but the false negatives don't matter as
much because
um well they don't matter as much
um so yeah any any positive you get from
that then you you know break it into
groups of ten whatever
i don't know exactly what the protocols
are but yeah um you actually can just
like
really quickly get through a whole bunch
of tests this way and
and rule out okay all you guys are safe
and you can like still be careful but
you can go about your business
right yeah but what i'm trying to get
past is the sense
that what has unfolded is a vindication
for the side that wasn't all that
worried about this in the first place i
am
you know if anything more worried than i
was because of all the things we don't
know and the fact that we
what we've learned is pretty frightening
even if it doesn't amount to
sudden death for people so the point is
look i don't really want responsibility
for what to do now
i want to say what should we have done
then and who was saying that
why didn't we listen to those voices and
what are they saying now
right that that i think is what we
should be doing and it doesn't amount to
let's end this lockdown already this was
a false alarm because that's not that's
not what happened
[Music]